[Music]
[Music]
once upon a time
on a beautiful country day the birds
weren't
singing the fish weren't jumping and
there was not a hopping rabbit
to be found for everyone was gathered to
celebrate
two very special people and what can
only be described
as a storybook wedding
[Music]
i promised myself i wouldn't cry well
that was dumb
welcome friends we are gathered here
today to join b
and thomas in holy matrimony you're
taking this so
well he's a good man makes her happy and
also a special day for their family
the beloved rabbits your former enemy is
here to stay
we found common ground he's about to be
a guardian
now this is just a little something
between them the old you would have gone
absolutely bonkers berserk by now i've
changed cousin
welcoming a new parent a loaded hand
grenade just
waiting to explode not anymore a father
if you will father father
you're not my father
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
you'll never be my father and everyone
can see your underpants
peter peter peter
peter the ring
right right where happened
you only have two pockets you may now
kiss the groom
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
huh
[Applause]
so b and mr mcgregor were married and
off they went on their honeymoon
things couldn't have been more peaceful
in windermere
until sometime later
[Music]
you just take this out you see
yeah you try
dad it's peter rabbit from the book oh
i hate that i'm the face of this
but every story can only have one good
guy so
peter doesn't have a dad he got put in a
pie that's why he's so naughty
what and that's flopsy mopsy and
cottontail i'm flopsy
and i'm mopsy and i'm the hero but i'm
not naughty
did this kid even read the book did you
read the book
i am so busy i'm saving it for summer
are you the author i'm still getting
used to people calling me that
it's really the rabbit story i just
wrote it down
this is my husband he's our publisher oh
i wouldn't say publisher
i just uh i just do the type setting and
turned our dining room into a printing
workshop created the artisanal
lithography with a five color palette
for the illustrations apart from ones in
the garden which call for more green
don't reveal all your secrets darling
well it's wonderful
you paint the rabbits with such love
well it comes naturally
it's our family thanks for your
contribution it goes directly to
preserving their land
thank you bye bye
afternoon congratulations you too thanks
moira
all the mail choose to see who gets it
just
how does he always win because he
invented the game
peter is that you johnny
what are you doing out of london we're
just up here doing some cheese tasting
heard about the wedding any babies yet
it's only been a month
the wife and i have had 15 kids in that
time this is the first day away from
them and oh the peace and quiet
but i'd be lying to you if i said we
didn't miss them terribly and they're
all we talk about
them oh cute but there's no babies we're
their family
until you're not congratulations on the
book by the way
my kids absolutely loved it oh it's not
about me it's just great that kids get
to read about positive role models
like me peter
oh dear my cheese well good luck
i'm sure it was just an accident it's
not an accident
it's what he does he never behaves
he loves you don't listen to him he
doesn't listen to me that's the problem
he can't understand me can he no
but still just if he can't understand me
then why can't i say
this i'm scared
just say something nice um
i'm sorry peter i love you in the way
that an adult
human loves a an animal rabbit
thank you
you handled that very well peter
contrite apologetic and
even a little bit remorseful i'm sorry
what
oh i put these in for when i'm feeling
misunderstood
oh come on peter sometimes you have to
face the
music oh and these are for when i'm
feeling ganged up on
you always take things one step too far
i'm sorry
what what's this basil jones publishing
we carried a whole section of their
books at harrods it was the last display
i arranged before i resigned
you mean fired and physically removed
from the store potato potato
it's from nigel basil jones himself he
wants to
publish my book no
guess in every bookstore promote it put
it in different languages
that's incredible b you've done it this
is it
it's happening promise me something when
this book is a huge success
you'll keep me humble the book is about
all of us
oh thank you you're already doing it
think
[Music]
why do you always copy everything i do
fine i'll do something different
oh sorry anyone hungry yes
starving leave it with me
okay take one bite and pass it around
i'm just going to wait until we get home
where the food isn't decomposing
yeah yeah me too well la
i didn't realize i was with a bunch of
sophisticates
[Music]
let's go get some dinner
[Music]
and there they go right through the
opening where there once was a gate
good for them do they do any of the
planting and weeding and watering
no they don't but they were here first
exactly
and you still have your tomatoes my
tomatoes
i would never have thought a city man
would like to garden that much
i even heard he wants to try and sell
them at market
it's too moist i'll get the hair dryer
it's about time he had a hobby i just
hope he's as successful at his as i'm at
mine
and what is that passing judgment
what is going on with her hair